this is a hologram most of us probably
hadn't thought much about Holograms
since that scene in Star Wars you know
the one r2d2 projecting Princess Leia
holograms made a brief appearance again
in 2012 when rapper Tupac Shakur
appeared on stage at the Coachella Music
Festival sixteen years after Tupac there
was speculation on other uses for the
technology mostly focusing on the
entertainment industry but Holograms
have now popped up in an unexpected
place alien politics the convene
election is the biggest on the planet
with over 800 million eligible voters so
if you're a candidate how do you reach
all in what is believed to be the
general election campaign first Narendra
Modi is using hologram technology to
connect with the electorate wastewater
treatment Gauri Modi's 3d hologram rally
allows him to hold 100 rallies
simultaneously voting finished on May
12th and it is estimated that Modi will
have reached 14 million extra voters
through his hologram rallies gauging
success will take a little longer
results will be announced on May 16th
he's no word yet on whether we can
expect Hillary hologram for 2016